I turn out all of my lights here other
than the brush right there I'm driving
in a milk
bottle if this gets any worse I'm
done so what I'm going to do is try to
pick my way back following my
tracks the wind and the snow is just
filling them in as rapidly as I'm making
them this was just a few minutes ago and
they're already half full I may be have
an hour and I'm going to lose all my
trail I only needed half of a day to get
up to the coast get my water and run
back
home but this winter is what it is
nature is what it is and it said nope
here you go hold my beer I'm going to
hit her with it
now I think one of the educational
things I'm getting this year from the
whole planet as much as I hate failure
it's not failure it's the ability to
recognize when you need to back
down I've been full-blown charging
through my life since I was Tiny and I
think I need a few of these lessons to
let's back out of this before it's too
late I am glad I turned around when I
did there is so much drifting going on
here I'm getting turned around a little
I can see my Barrel so I know I'm at the
end of the runway here um I think I am
anyways yeah here I am
there my garden is
there lights are
there oh wow what the heck is
that oh that's my
Cox scared
myself what has he
got oh all
right this is
uh this is the
remnant of a caribou I got a while
back oh I got a couple of foxes here I
don't have a lot of caribou
left I actually want to get out they're
acting really
weird that's a pretty big print
there those are pretty big
prints this is the Caribou I got I don't
know a little while ago and when I laid
it here it was all
flat but uh I can see right here
something has snapped the vertebrae
there I've got a big hole down here I've
got a big hole on that
side feel
around I've got bright red blood in
there yeah I don't want to get too
involved in
that what does that a wolverine will get
on the underside of the kill and like
this is snap it and pull it under snap
it and pull it under bury it pee all
over it now look at the
snow look at how much I'm getting this
is all brand
new that right there is
recent I don't want to spend my time in
the dark in a storm trying to figure out
who's eating at my table
Uninvited m cavic is
mine so I want to know who's roaming
around in it and if it's a big top
predator I've got got to know that but
right now I can't do much my hands are
getting bright red my temp is really
dropping the snow is coming in hard I
want to get home and as long as I can
see get out here and see who's in my
yard who's awaking doing something cuz
right now I'm betting it's bigger than a
fox
[Music]